I know you fielded calls for stuff I've
said before at least I know AOS about
artists have you ever had to deal with
blowback for like early Charlemagne
stuff where they're like yo
before real you were you're obviously
based in Jacksonville but like you're at
the I feel like you're kind of the face
of like yeah who the industry talks to
when it comes to I heart [__] on the
hip-hop side you are that literally so
was there ever any like always always
um especially at the very early
different iterations of Charlemagne I
think early on he was he was wrong
and so um I get those complaints
obviously back in the day before uh
Charlemagne star was it was routine man
like NAACP would want me to come like
I'm not coming into the movies like nah
man like like if you took the show
locally I would always tell them like
you you took the show you know what you
got like you got to handle it like I'm
not flying across the country and
meeting with the you know United Eagle
college fund NAACP every city because
every city that that was Affiliated
affiliated with the show because they
were hot you know um so but um but yeah
I mean there were there were there were
complaints it's part of the culture I
just I'm just wondering if like you know
you look at your phone and like it says
Diddy's calling right and then Diddy's
like yo yo doc
this is [__] by the way that's just
the name yeah yeah I mean it still
happens to this day yeah I mean I think
um some people think that that's what we
do we we set them up for the um you know
to get the clip on on social media which
I don't think you guys intentionally do
I think it just happens sometimes but
yeah
but yeah get them a lot do you feel like
because I do I I I don't think um
artists at least even five ten years
back appreciate
the radio promo run like they used to
you know what I mean like I feel like a
lot of these younger guys didn't
necessarily break on radio and or
understand the importance of radio or do
you notice that in terms of like certain
artists maybe not wanting to do
you know come to the station or do a
radio run or do like a promo show [__]
like that not a lot but some yeah
um again just not well educated I think
they've fallen into the fantasy of
streaming which you know I don't
necessarily buy it buy it all that it's
legitimate I I think if you want to be a
household name though you want to be on
the radio yeah I wish everybody I say
look you have a career you could be big
you get but if you win a number one
record
especially markets like La where people
are always in the car right like you
know and
you know people always talk about you
know radios ability to survive man like
the best talent in the world is on the
radio like you know you could you could
you could put on a playlist but I'd
rather hear you and James talk about
something and then play my favorite
record or you and big right or The
Breakfast Club or we just have a lot of
great talent in our stable and you know
I think they're they're going to take us
into the next that's what I was gonna
say in terms of like obviously radio as
an industry is like shrinking in terms
of like the amount of bodies that are
around like yeah like even like on the
record side you know people are getting
let go it's it just it feels like more
and more the if you think I like the UK
and they have BBC do you feel like
eventually they'll be like some I don't
think they'll ever be like a BBC type
situation in the US I just think there's
too many companies involved yeah but do
you feel like eventually they'll they'll
be something similar where it's like
this is the morning show for the U.S
this is the you know what I mean like do
you feel like it's gonna get there or no
I don't think so because I think
I I think big makes sense for LA right I
think didn't make sense for New York he
was on 97 for a little bit no yeah I
probably never told him this story but I
remember my boss calling me and saying
hey should should we do this and and I'd
met big loved him and I think you know
growing up in New York City I was like
no it's a different vibe 100 there's
cities there's cities that are like that
yeah like he's one of the funniest most
talented people I've ever met for sure
and and I mean that sincerely but New
York is just a different animal it is
and New Yorkers are they want to hear
New Yorkers on the radio they want to
know you're there they want to know yeah
and you got to have a little you know it
could be a little nasty at times you
know and that's their expectation and
they deserve to get what it is that they
want you know